je voyais pas venir habiter ici qu'on
pouvait plus payer les traites de la
maison et la faire sur laquelle je
travaille c'est passé près d'ici
l'histoire sera bien cette fois je vais
écrire le meilleur livre de tous les
temps qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc la
pendaison de crémaillère barbecue 1970
c'est la famille qui vivait ici
vous croyez que c'est des meurtres en
série
je sais pas le premier remonte aux
années 60
le seul lien entre tous ces meurtres
c'est ce symbole ce dessin est associé
occulte d'une divinité païenne dont le
nom est baghouli et l'enlève les enfants
et dévore lentement leurs armes
je n'ai jamais été sur un truc aussi
énorme
qu'est ce que tu as fait jury dix ans je
voulais faire son portrait de qu'est-ce
que tu parles
qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce qui se
passe
il faut qu'on parte maintenant